[Music]
hello everyone my name is vitaly namer I
am the game master resident here at the
same foolish chess club and today we
have a special day as you can see I'm
wearing a special shirt recognizing a
Fabiano's win today
over Alex on a greased choke and yes yes
go Fabi we had a huge celebration here
at the Chess Club and it's a really
special moment not only for Fabiano for
for winning the this that championship
but also for the United States chess
overall so for the a no good luck and
we're all supporting behind you and now
let's let's get back to our lesson today
today we're gonna have a strategy class
today is gonna be our second part of the
engine match that we discussed
previously previously we looked at some
of the history and some pros and cons of
using chess engines some of the best
fights and today we're going to look at
some other games that were played in
that match last time we focused on one
of the games which was called the
ultimate machine war in where alpha0
played white pieces and as we discuss
the opening population the opening
choices what was played by alpha zero we
now know that he prefer to play the move
d4 or Knight of T or c4 so today we are
going to look at another game where
alphas yo played with the black pieces
and it's gonna be interesting to see
what kind of a reply he made it with the
black pieces so stockfish decided to
start with this movie for as is first as
its first move and we know that against
e4 black has many choices
pretty much 'if I've c5 d v e6 d66 so
many options today
but alpha zero decides to go with a
simple V 5 and by the way and referring
to the candidates tournament most of the
time like the black candidates have
played ie 5 themselves that's that's
considered the most one of the most
solid answers against efore if you are
more than a a shout player you like more
tactics you probably will go to c5 if
you like close positions you should play
a six if you like a combination of a
closed position and a and a shout
position you should publish play c6 but
if I was playing in a game night of 396
is the best move and Bishop to b5 so
stockfish is entering their who is
entering their real opens I also called
the Spanish defense probably the most
played opening of all times with it with
the first movie for today Bishop c4 is
slightly more more fashionable but
Bishop to b5 was played in the game now
here alpha zero made an interesting
choice the the most popular move is of
course this moved EC a6 with a wood
black driving black this Knight back to
a for what the bishop obviously can also
take the 1996 but recently in touches in
top-level chess we have seen this move
Knight to f6 which was played by alpha 0
and this is what is known the Berlin
defence of the of the Spanish opening so
Knight of 6 is a pretty pretty simple
move just developing that the tonight's
makes lots of logic so he really white
piece to figure out what to play what
what would be his plan alpha zero
decided I'm sorry our stockfish decided
not to follow the main line which is a
castle but instead he played the pawn to
d3
now just to just to show you the main
line of the building defense white
usually castles black snaps the spawn of
efore d4 is being played
night coming back to the six attacking
this Bishop on b5 this is one of the
reasons why we don't play a six
ourselves because we want to keep the
bishop here we're so really through the
night with the tempo mm-hmm the bishop
takes 26 poun takes 26 politics only
five Knight to f5 and the Queen captures
on d8 and King captures on d8 so this is
what is well known as the building
endgame it is called the building
endgame because of the Berlin Wall as
everybody knows which was built in
Europe in Germany which divided Germany
and you know obviously as a as any other
wall it was considered very very solid
and this is why it got the name the
Berlin wall because it's very solid
yeah White has many many options here I
would say that about 10 or 20 years ago
this this disposition looked very and
sound for black to play because it looks
like black is just you know black is
just losing a castle he lost his castle
he has two double points here on c6 so
it looks - pretty bad like a bad
position to play for black but the idea
for black is that you know first of all
we are in an endgame so we don't mind
the fact that the king is in the center
of the board
the second the second advantage that
Beck has is those two bishops and this
is a long-term advantage even even today
we know that it's pretty difficult to to
get an advantage out of the opening I
mean you need to other have very good
opening preparation or or your opponent
needs to play some kind of a risky line
so even so even today if if a player
gets the - bishop advantage out of the
opening without any you know too much
other advantages like space or anything
else that's supposed to be enough and it
makes make us happy so this is the main
line of the building defense it was not
played in a game instead stockfish
decided to play this move d3
more of a subtle move for to play for
for--why just defending the pawn keeps
all the options open does not get into
it into an end game okay so by the way
we have seen one of those one of those
positions happened in the candidates
tournament here and which was played by
Aronian he decided to play this
variation against Kramnik so who knows
what is the what is the move here that
was the best move here to play for black
yes wrote the g8 now okay it was route
to jet later
not exactly now it's it's a bit risky
right now Bishop Knight to d6 the seek
will be a little bit passive because we
won't be able to develop develop this
Bishop on c8 but yes you're correct
Bishop to c5 it's very simple you know
just like in the Italian game the bishop
usually goes to c5 you know if you can
put the Bishop on c5 instead of d6o e7
that's Nestor that's the way to put it I
mean there's no reason why not to put it
there we are definitely not losing a
pawn here for example Bishop takes c6 we
can just take a little poll on c6 and if
the knight takes only five exactly Queen
to d4 you guys know your tactics well
let me show you another tactic in this
position there's a very very surprising
trap instead of Bishop black playing
Bishop to c5 black can play this very
unusual move Knight to e7
does anybody know what's the name of
this of this trap it doesn't make sense
right why would we why would we bring
our nine two three seven eight I mean it
is the whole opposite of we of us
starting chess you know we will bring a
knight back we basically block our
bishop
like our Queens almost looks like we are
preparing to to get smothered however
this is this is very tempting here for
white to take this de-spawn here only
five and this this variation is called
the Mortimer trap the Mortimer trap it
was named after the American player
James Mortimer and he was the one of the
first ones who played it so what's the
idea what happens if Knight snaps this
pawn on e5 exactly c6 attacking the
bishop the bishop has to go back let's
say Bishop a4 and Queen to a5 perfect oh
that hurts that hurts same same thing
with Bishop c4 and just to trap you just
a little bit why can't play this move
Knight to c4 what to do here exactly see
we don't want to take the bishop on on
d5 because we're gonna check ass model
made it on on d6 attribute you put me on
the trap I'm going to trap you
so what to play here with black yeah so
it's other d5 all simply d6 and now we
maintain all of our threats if Bishop to
a4 we don't have Queen a5 but we can
just simply play b5 and work the bishop
and the night yeah so this is the multi
mode trap now obviously if now you know
this you obviously don't won't take only
5 and if white can simply castle well
that's pretty much it you know now now
we are in a much worse position okay
let's go back to the game
so Bishop c5 was played was played in
the game why to consist six D Turks on
c6 pretty much
following that that game Aronian the
chronic and now a White Castle okay so
here he was the he was the first change
between the games cramming played this
more logical move Queen to e7 defending
the the pawn on d5 instead alpha0
decided to play this strange move Knight
to d7 what is what is this move is it
like a another some kind of a multimode
trap first
alpha0 style so the idea of course the
in the first side we can see that the
knight is simply defending the pawn on
e5 and but what why to d7 why why would
we block our Bishop and and our queen
well the plan is going to be revealed in
a few in a few moves so let's see what
happened white played c3 obviously white
is trying to push default like in any
other before almost almost any other
before opening black simply cancelled
and now why play d4 attacking the bishop
on c5 and the pawn on e5 okay so I will
move here with black but what do we do
here would black do we take the pawn on
d4 do we ignore the threat do we run do
we run and if we do run where do we run
so what to do he would black what are we
the best choice okay interesting so your
idea is to take on d4 pawn takes and
then Bishop to before okay anybody has
any other ideas Knight to f6
okay just ignoring the threat okay
Bishop d6 okay go moving the bishop
backwards okay Bishop b6 you guys almost
Center all possible choices the only
question is which one of them is the
best one we the tiebreaker fish of the
six yes thank you very much and Bishop
d6 is the correct move let's see let's
see why let's see why for example that
if I take the pawn on d4 pawn takes on
d4 this is just going to help white why
it's going to get the solid solid
central here and if we move Bishop to
before well I'm gonna get under attack
and we'll get an attack again and then
white would simply develop his knight on
c3 nice center no problems for white and
so this is not so good
obviously sacrificing that the bishop is
just a little bit too premature don't
forget that even after we sacrifice the
bishop on c5 we're probably there's a
like high likelihood that we are going
to exchange Queens and without the
Queen's within an endgame with a piece
down I would not want to play stockfish
in that position I guess that fish so
the choice is between Bishop d6 and
Bishop d6 well we need to defend the
point so Bishop d6 we have to retreat to
the to defender
okay so so far so good Bishop to g5 was
played by by by stock fish attacking our
queen on d8 Queen e8 was played we just
move the Queen back rook e1 so white is
developing his forces and now comes the
whole idea behind this interesting move
ninety seven the whole idea is for black
here to play this move f6 hmm
exactly some people say never play f6
but I say don't believe those people
because here we are
we are playing of six now what so
usually the problem in f6 or a5 is that
we are weakening this this diagonal
now if Y tries to check us that's no
problem because Queen f7 and I'm fine
with exchange in the Queen's and going
going into an endgame so why is this
move f6 is so good well simply because
the bishop here on g5 needs to find a
place for himself it's not so easy what
would I put the bishop here on the tree
well it's gonna block the rock only one
if I put it on d2 it's gonna block my
queen and my knight
obviously I'm not gonna go back home to
c1 so the bishop goes to h4 and when the
bishop goes to H show it looks like the
bishop is developed it looks like white
the white knight here is doing a great
job they're both developed but they're
actually not this is this is one of
those kind of a wall I would call it a
fence offence which which blocks in the
restricts the the snide and Bishop it's
very very effective while we can can
transpose all our pieces to some other
better squares excellent question so the
question was why didn't we will play f6
here before Queen e8 anybody wants to
know because what
right so you can either take on e5 or or
the member because our queen is not here
you can also check us on b3 again it's
probably not that deadly let's check
what we have to move a king and
eventually I will need to move my queen
again so I prefer to move to put to
place the Queen and f7 good question so
Bishop to h4 Queen to f7 now as you can
see when we are playing the the bill in
defense or any kind of evilly five
opening especially the building defense
the game is much slower it's most
symmetrical there's much more
maneuvering going on and you know it's
not like the the dreaded the student
dragons although Odin either for we see
a sacrifices all the time
in this this is a much slower pace 92
was played so now white is just develop
in the night a5 black does want to get
some space on the Queen side Bishop g3
white understood that that the bishop on
each hole is not doing much so he put
some pressure on this pony five rook to
e8 Queen to c2 and now it is time for us
to do some how to develop to put
somewhere else this Knight and Bishop so
black decides to play Knight to f8 not
well that will be sure what the night is
going to but what definitely should et
it's not the best girlfriend to stay on
this era c4 is being played the idea is
to push up our Bishop back by by playing
c5 and once the bishop goes to e7 then
white can take on d4 so black to move
how do we how do we fight this threat
okay we can either take on d4 right what
else can we do you can play what you can
take on d4 yes you can do that you can
play c5 yeah
b5 okay come to attack interesting
bishop before okay so one of the one of
the moves that you guys mentioned it was
the correct one
there's also 96 yeah so okay let's let's
look at those if I play Bishop before
here
then why I can simply take this pawn on
d5 b5 same thing it's just too
aggressive c5 will fall and I'm going to
take on e5 there's pretty much only
helping white White's plan so Knight is
sixth the same thing probably just taken
only five because we would locked but
blocking arak so that pretty much leaves
us two options do we take on d4 or we do
play or do we played on c5 and I assume
that obviously alpha zero with this
calculation power try to evaluate his
options but taking on d4 would really
release White's pieces so instead he
played this move c5 and white obviously
does not want to take on c5 because if
it takes on c5 Bishop takes 25 and I
will see this amazing position suddenly
this fence becomes a wall there's no way
for white to move those pawns really
really this this time is going to get
stuck as well as this type of 92 all
right now Bishop on c5 will become very
very active and I don't need to tell you
what's gonna happen after the Knights
gonna come to e6 and d4 it's gonna be a
disaster for for white at some point so
obviously why this decides not to take
what to play d5 okay
so let's look let's look at this
position let's do a small evaluation
assessment of the position
so we got into some kind of a closed
position
maybe semi-closed I would say actually
it's pretty closed and we know that in
the closed positions nights are
preferable over bishops because they can
jump around but this position is quite
unique because if you look if you look
at white knights they can they cannot
really they don't have real outposts in
those in this position so it's not going
to be so easy for Y to play d5
exactly yeah so so sometimes so those
pawns on evil and see for the arrow
Knights on Knights way and something
white even try to sacrifice them at some
point but black just didn't given him
any choice
okay so d5 was played black players be
six and nine th for so white white is
trying to to get to spot an opening were
to put his Knights he looks at a five he
likes a five well obviously we don't
give it we don't let him wait ing six
now the knight on a non h4 looks little
bit of silly
so the knight just moves back if you if
you see those moves happening in the
game like night h4 Knight f3 that means
that something is going is going wrong
in the game you know stockfish is not
not having any plans here Bishop d7 was
played a simple move developing the
Bishop rook a e1 and now black continues
his development rookie 7h3 and Queen g7
rook a to e8 okay lots of money when
going on as you see very very slow game
very close game by the way we know that
in history the engines the chess engines
are not playing so well in closed
positions the don't really understand
some of those out flanking maneuvers and
some of those exploding moves in the
center so it's really interesting to see
what what what's gonna happen a3 was
played in out h6 so h6 the smoke
basically black put made a battery of
rooks and he is ready to push f4
I'm sorry f5 and then f4 but he can't do
it immediately because of Bishop h4 90
g5 so he plays h6 first preparation
okay well stockfish sees that and he
plays Bishop h4 he pins the rock okay
now before we continue into into looking
at this game
[Music]
ICO I call this game the draw offer
between chess engines now if you think
about when somebody is awful in a draw
you know over the board and there's a
match within two players the only thing
you have to do is to offer a job usually
a you do it once you made a move
otherwise your pawns gonna ask you to
make a move but what about engines how
do how do they offer a joy if there's a
match do they have like a unique button
or something like a cold exactly so the
only way that they can do it is by
repeating the moves we use that that
rule of threefold repetition of of the
same position so here's what happens
here
Bishop h4 route to f7 he comes out of
the pin prepares a five again well white
moves the bishop to g3 now we cannot
clarify because white is going to have
just too many attackers on this 'if I've
pawn so like the sides to go back F 37
Bishop h4 was played it's great
broke f7r ogt anybody's counting the
moves okay here is where black in black
going to play rook F to e7 white can
claim a job it's gonna be at the total
time that it's gonna happen but what
does it do
well we know that black won the game so
he refuses alpha zero refuses to the
joint place this subtle move a for now
why would we why would he refuse though
why would we repeat some moves in a
chess game and then refuse to draw
anybody knows we're a few earth-gravity
I think three reasons yes so now reason
number one is when we're in time
pressure lots of lots of the games that
we are playing today
they include increment so even half a
minute to the seconds can make the
difference if you'll be the two times
you get a minute so I mean it's pretty
important so this that's reason number
one what's reason number two anybody
knows yes please
yeah they are correct so your opinion
the moves to see maybe he doesn't make
the draw or maybe he is going to chicken
out and make something else you know the
nerves what Susan reason number three
you know though that feeling that you
know you come to the game you don't
really want to play the game or maybe
you want to make a draw or you're
feeling blue and let's say you get to
the point where you start to repeat
moves and then your opponent starts to
repeat moves so you're happy yeah he is
repeating the moves okay just one more
move and I can I can claim my draw and
suddenly he makes a different move
what's gonna what is what is it going to
do to you right like psychologically you
know I think oh my god I mean come on I
have to stay here and I will play the
game I mean so psychologically it can
imbalance you know the state of mind
yeah but what about computers you know
do they have psychological adji computer
psychology maybe with let's say that's a
new major we have to invent right yeah
yeah exactly
ah maybe a fuzzy Oh has emotions yes
that much that might be true yeah yeah
they do think more like humans more and
more so very interesting or you know all
he plays like like Magnus Carlsen even a
nindroid positions that still tries to
squeeze right as long as I'm as long as
I have some chances for a win I will
still go I'm still gonna play and that's
it that's pretty amazing obviously you
won't be playing continue with in a lost
position but here you know not even
close to be losing okay well let's see
what happens so a faux play was traded
King h1 so why this says okay well you
made kind of a waiting move I'm just
gonna wait with my king okay after three
seven well guess what I'm gonna repeat
that again Bishop h4 hooked f7 Bishop to
ho2 ji3 rook to e7 o 2h 4 and now if
back again please loop to f7 again we
have another threefold repetition but
Fazio says not so fast buddy and he
plays this move g5 he is ready to attack
Bishop - GT was playing 96 right so that
was the idea of g5 now we have a nice
spot for the night here so every
movement has a reason of every every
move
okay well g5 also created a weakness so
I'd never move as an advantage in a
disadvantage so what's the disadvantage
of this move g5 exactly f5 so the move
that stockfish played 90 fun you guys
playing like 3600 players night to f1
route 2 F 7-9 to 83 and we cannot allow
white to enter with this night here on
to a 5 because not only the night
antle's here if we take is gonna open up
some files so black plays Knight 3 7
back just defending showing what you got
Queen D 3 and now H 5 continue continue
with the pawn push okay well white
cannot allow black to push too much like
H show on g4 so he decides to block the
pawn himself by playing h4 okay so now
starts a very interesting maneuver that
that black is doing here and the
question you need to ask yourself is
what is what is blacks worst piece what
is blacks worst piece in this position
exactly his dark squared bishop on d6 so
he's trying to find a spot for the
bishop obviously if I could if I could
teleport and put the bishop on d4 this
would be nice would be an awesome new
move in chess but we can't so anybody
anybody can cut to figure out well the
bishop goes on which diagonal he would
be maybe more supportive
exactly
here on h6 after we move the pawn he's
gonna be able to travel all along that
diagonal so we start with moving all
night Knight to c8 rookie to g4 was
played 92 he moves the Queen and Bishop
to f8 and by the way now our best black
headers are Knights not bishops so it is
perfect for us to put the knight on on
d6 it's almost it almost looks like it's
a puzzle you know almost looks like he
knows exactly where to put each piece
it's pretty amazing and Bishop to to h6
was played okay rook f1 so yeah so so
black approve these pieces this position
looks nicer but it's still not so easy
to win so it makes a wedding move okay
one okay eight king h2 okay
so in this position alpha zero things
okay I am I'm winning I don't have a
plan here clear to plan you know what
what to do i'm i'm obviously attacking
on the queenside nothing not on the King
side so what to do I mean if I play a
five year Lea five is hanging if I try
to open up the the Kings side again my
King might get exposed so what we're
doing here black to move
yes Campus Bishop f4 is possible and
then what let's say I just make some
some random of King h1 ok King h2 mmm
Bishop g5 Wow that's a that's a very
interesting move you know what I'm not
hungry
how are the ate today I'm just gonna
taking h1 okay that may be possible but
then you know if your Bishop is gonna be
on g5 I'll probably take on the five and
I'll take the bishop on g5 so here he
finds this this very nice idea he plays
King to her fate there are two two
purposes to this move came to her fate
there are two purposes for this move
purpose number one well maybe the king
is going to walk walk walk two to c8 and
take shelter on b7 relocation of the
king but there's another there's another
purpose why stockfish sees he's a
software he sees that his rook now is
aligned in front of the king he's
thinking I wish I could open up this
file I wish I could check in with my
rogue and this was a really good
provocation so let's see let's see what
happens in the game he plays King G on
the first and now pushes f4 it wants to
open up the position now in my opinion
this might be this might have been the
losing move for white we don't know what
would happen in the game if white would
never make this this move this weakness
on a4 she plays a4 and black says yes
but gotcha
it takes ampersand
rook takes exchanged the bishop the
bishop now King finds safety on e7 and
now we have a bunch of rook exchanges so
rue comes to g7 exchanges exchange the
rooks come with the Queen to h6 this
position it doesn't look so bad for
white but it's pretty terrible the back
rank is very sad and especially this
night is so good
attacking those backward pawns on c4 and
E for white wishes that he could bring
the pawn here to d3 and bring his Knight
to d5 somehow but unfortunately that is
not legal in chess so he plays Knight d2
Bishop g4 look at all of our pieces just
pretty good and now he starts to squeeze
squeeze him like an orange
kingi King H to King de 7 b3 takes takes
Queen g6 attacking the spawn 92 now it
turns transposes his Bishop to a4 very
nice maneuver place queen g4 just keep
making small adjustments to his position
small improvements Queen f3 Bishop d1
and he's okay with exchange in the
Queen's now Quinte is g4 okay so how
should we take the Queen on g4 should we
take it with the pawn or should we take
it to the bishop and while in one of the
moves you're going forward in one moves
you're going backwards
sure shouldn't we go forward all the
time should let mathematically be better
for us okay so we have one more for the
pawn and luckily we're having an odd
number of audience here so we need a
tiebreaker
you have three for the ponty for the
bishop so we have fall for the pawn wait
wait so what's the other two changes now
still the tie
oh no okay cool let me just repeat what
you said so you said you would prefer to
like with a poem because the H pawn is
not a thread because you're in the
square and then you're then you're also
gonna restrict the night
now this position is all about the
potential that you're giving to your
opponent okay not not exactly what what
happens immediately but the potential so
when we take with a pawn on g4 we create
this past poem on the edge file right
now it's not that it's not as exactly a
big threat but I know that I'm gonna
have to keep one of my pieces the King
here all the night to stop it now in
regards to restricting the 92 you're
correct I cannot go to f3 but that's one
of the wonders of the night I can jump
around Knight f3 the 93 and we can
attack this pawn on g4 so the correct
move was Bishop takes on g4 exactly you
gotta listen to your heart okay God
listen to your heart
so Bishop takes on on g4 do not create
those passers yeah f5 we could do and in
any case but now the idea is that white
cannot do anything with this pawns this
age porn stabs those two pawns on on on
h4 and g2 and if you remember when we
had the lessons about prophylaxis one of
those n games that we discussed there
was also similar bone structure but one
point stop two points and that's why
really black has the advantage here okay
so a four was has been played in the
game he's trying to exchange this
despawned on a four with the idea of a
five then he was to take one c5
so black would play what 97 yes stop him
you know at all cost
don't give him any chance night to be
one night to 85 attacking this weakness
on c4
Bishop to e3 now why decides to give up
the spawn on on on c4 there is no way to
save it simply because after 92 then we
can just simply play Bishop e2 and
that's it the pawn is lost now it's
interesting to mention that that we are
going to get into some kind of a
opposite color Bishop endgame after
exchanging the Knights but black spawns
are all defendant even by the king but
the pawn on e4 and a and a foe is gonna
be it's gonna be a huge liability for
for--why to defend so this is why why
decides to just to give up this pawn so
if a bishop East III Knight takes on c4
Bishop to c1 okay Bishop to d7 attacking
this this pawn on on a4 Knight to c3
okay so looks like white consolidated
his position defending all his
weaknesses the bishop on on c1 is kind
of restricting your night doing a good
job not not allowing the knight to come
any any further and in here at the pawns
so what to do next with black knight on
c3 is overloaded okay but how do we use
that okay we can play 96 and then what
would you sacrifice one of your pieces
to get two points that's that's actually
a brave idea you can do that but yeah
yeah it's very risky I'm not sure if if
that if that would work exactly
okay another idea here the audience is
to bring the king all the way to a5
let's see I like this idea what's the
problem with this idea right so when the
King leaves his home unattended
well the thieves are gonna come in c6
and what's the idea
yeah exactly and not exactly not the the
main idea is not just to attack the e4
pawn right the idea is simply is because
we have those double points we don't
like double pawns or motion in any in
any position so we just want to get rid
of them so let's exchange the double
pond see citrus trade not keen to g1
black to 25 why to put a pawn on d5
Bishop to a5 a restriction of the of the
night black has all the time in the
world in this in this position King - f2
Knight goes to back to the six as you
can see the maneuvering continues in
this game Bishop to e3 and now black
plays Knight to e4 exchanging the
Knights now I have to say that using
this this technique in a real game is I
think it's not necessarily I think it's
very dangerous if you are the one who is
playing for win to start exchanging you
know the Knights in here because you're
gonna get into an opposite color Bishop
endgame and those 10 games usually and
end up in a draw so I don't know if it
was it was if it was my opinion I would
keep try to keep the Knights as much as
possible but you know alpha zero is
calculating millions of positions and
variations in a second his probably
knows what he's doing and the idea here
is that that after they exchange the d5
pawn is is falling it there's no way to
defend it so why try to play a five pawn
takes on a5 Bishop takes on c5 in kt7
so we we are only a pawn down and lots
of opposite color Bishop end games were
drawn before with two points now even
three pawns down but the problem is that
those pawns we have two passers that is
the real problem if we have only one
pair so we're then white might block it
it but two passes is too much so let's
see what happens
d6 okay so once the what's the plan here
for black how would you guys play play
this this one
do we just push the pawn on the ohne I
mean we can just move make one move a
four but what what's there was the real
plan here
exactly so the bishop will come to - to
block this de-spawn to defend this is
exactly what happened the game bishop
280 and now the King comes in yeah so
the question was can you put the pawns
on f4 and e4 you can put them here but
then I can attack the pony only for
right now those two points are now
squares which which enables Y to attack
them maybe here but it's gonna be hit
taking so much time every time you're
gonna push up on it will be much easier
for me to attack them okay so Bishop f5
king c6
and King to d5 into d2 and now the idea
for wife is that if we play King to c4
maybe you can try to block it with it
with a king so he changed it changes
sides it goes suddenly to the left his
shift Bishop e2 was played
but then the King just moves around and
he captures all the pawns there before
Kings a stage four so H ro is not so
important because it's it's not giving
us a pass form but it will in the future
so let's see how the game ended King F -
King G for Bishop to 83
Bishop to d7 and now it decides to bring
his King all the way back and here is
the idea so in this position after some
some minutes of thought stockfish
resigned now why is that
let's look at an example variation if
weif just plays Bishop 18 Waits
now we're gonna start pushing all of our
points now if Y plays g3 what should we
do should we take on GT or should we not
take on GT nothing and play
HD very good get those passes in in
there clinging f2e for Kingi 183 Bishop
to c5 e - Bishop - before we stopped we
stopped everybody yay oh but we only
have two bodyguards and we have three
passers a tree and then that that's
pretty much it king h2 for example a -
bishop c1 and now the promote one of the
ponds and we will win the game so so a
very good game as you can see that from
the opening perspective fazil starts
with the move on if Ani Foley starts
with the move e5 and lots and lots of
maneuvering going on there
the Berlin defense is being featured
very very solid opening against against
the we Lopez thank you for joining me
today
I'm Vitaly namer here from the same
place chest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]